you're watching this on your electronic
device and guess what it's watching you
mass surveillance has become a buzz
phrase we say it and here is so often we
seem to forget that the government is
trampling on our Fourth Amendment rights
maybe it's because so many expected that
things couldn't get any worse after Bush
but they did America's surveillance
state has expanded under President
Barack Obama but how exactly did we end
up with the biggest domestic spying
apparatus in US history let's take it
back to george w bush following the 9/11
attacks President Bush authorized the
use of warrantless domestic wiretapping
with the goal of preventing future
attacks and three weeks after that he
signed the Patriot Act into law the
Patriot Act allowed for questionable
practices like indefinitely detaining
immigrants-- and allowing cops to search
your home or office without your consent
and these provisions would have a major
impact on several pre-existing laws like
the Foreign Intelligence Surveillance
Act of 1978 or FISA which established
procedures for authorizing the use of
intelligence gathering these security
reforms set the stage for American
surveillance and in 2002 the Pentagon
rolled out something called the Total
Information Awareness program the
program wanted to collect virtually
every kind of information available
about Americans we're talking about
everything from medical prescriptions to
browser history to even individual DNA
the program ended in 2003 after it was
blasted for its intrusiveness hmm I
wonder why but while TI a was disbanded
its technology wasn't in fact in 2005
the New York Times revealed that the
National Security Agency was spying on
thousands of Americans and it's believed
that it was actually using
technology and less than two years later
we learned that surveillance had
expanded to millions the NSA had
backdoor access to databases at Verizon
AT&T and BellSouth and in July 2008
these telecom companies even received
immunity from wrongdoing for
collaborating with the government when
the FISA Amendments Act was passed and
guess who voted in favor of the Act none
other than presidential candidate Barack
Obama before he was President Obama
senator Obama actually had a history of
voting against heightened surveillance
policies I will provide our intelligence
and law enforcement agencies with the
tools they need to track and take out
the terrorists without undermining our
Constitution and our freedom but he
changed his tune just months before
becoming commander-in-chief and well
into his presidency he said it's
important to recognize that you can't
have a hundred percent security and also
then have a hundred percent privacy and
zero inconvenience while Obama didn't
agree to extending immunity to telecom
companies he did vote yes to the FISA
Amendments Act which increased the
government's ability to eavesdrop on
domestic communications without a
warrant but when Director of National
Intelligence James clapper was asked in
a 2013 Senate Intelligence Committee
hearing about whether or not the NSA was
collecting information on Americans he
had a lot to say no sir it does not not
wittingly he kind of lied because as we
learned shortly after in June 2013
thanks to NSA whistleblower Edward
Snowden there actually was a pretty
intensive and vast surveillance program
prism while the program started in 2007
under Bush the Obama administration
expanded
and prism isn't just backdoor data
collection from telecommunications
companies the NSA is getting your
information from Internet giants like
Google AOL Apple and Yahoo so that means
they can snoop in your non-encrypted
chats and emails and they can even
access that macbook camera you love so
much so given how alarmed many folks
were after the Snowden revelations what
is the Obama administration done in 2014
they made some reforms for instance now
the NSA doesn't have as easy access to
phone records as it did before
instead phone companies store the data
and if the government wants it they have
to get a warrant from the secret court
but where the reforms even helpful I
mean after all they only focused on a
small part of the bigger data collection
effort and no surveillance program was
even dismantled and in May a federal
appeals court in New York ruled that NSA
bulk surveillance is in fact illegal the
Patriot Act actually doesn't allow for
it
but their right to privacy still be
saved do we need reforms or do we need
something more